a man arrested for sexual assault but
out on bond with electronic monitoring
is now back in jail accused of murder
the i-team has been digging into court
records to discover how these series of
events unfolded
vanessa murphy spoke to the victim's
mother in this exclusive interview
reynold pina castelleo is accused of
killing a man while he was
out on bond first he was accused of
sexually assaulting a child he was
arrested
and released now he's accused of beating
a man
who then died represented to me that
there is no conflict
pina costelleo faces murder and robbery
charges
metro police say he and his son robbed
and beat a man at a bus stop near twain
and university center on april
11. the alleged victim 32-year-old
cornell black
the clark county coroner's office
declaring his death a homicide due to
blunt force trauma to the head
records reveal pina castello was already
on house arrest
in 2019 he was arrested on three charges
in connection with the sexual assault of
a child
the allegations date back to 2013.
according to court documents judge joe
bonaventure allowed pina costelleo to
walk through
jail pay no bail and to be put on high
level
electronic monitoring a trial is set for
july
but in the meantime police say his gps
ankle bracelet revealed
he was at the bus stop at the time of
the alleged
deadly beating here's what cornell
black's mother has to say
the bracelet didn't stop nothing the
bracelet didn't stop nothing cause he
killed my son while he was wearing a
bracelet
so what did the bracelet do there was
confusion
in court today about finding a defense
attorney for pina costelleo
he's expected to be back in court
wednesday morning
vanessa murphy 8 news now